the licensing G for Friday the 20th of
October we're here to
review to to consider one item which is
the application for review of an
existing premises license o to Victoria
Warehouse tra Traer Park Road tra
Park so this being a licensing review is
not the usual format for for premises
license heing uh so Traer licensing of
the applicant
in this and Victoria where are the
respondent I
believe um so in terms of introductions
I'm councelor jman I'll be chairing the
hearing with me councilor Thomas and
NR uh we have uh offices from trafford's
uh legal licensing and
governance um Mr James Parry will be
representing Trapper's case for for the
LIC Department
uh and you'll be assisted by uh I have
with me um jade pickup who is deputizing
for CLA Whittle who of course can't be
with us unfortunately uh we have Suzanne
um Whitaker Nicola Duckworth Liz pitard
and I can't see
G Peter bfield and of course Joan uh bo
is with me who has prepared the
report okay so you you'll be bringing
various individuals in at various points
as necessary with with your leave what I
would propose to do chair is to open our
case yeah and then it may be appropriate
to hear from Mr CER as to who represents
um Victor excuse
me represents Victoria Ware housee uh
for observations and then it will
possibly be uh we can then map how the
remain remainder of the hearing of
meeting should should progress I know Mr
cry has indicated to me that there has
been a little bit of movement on his
client's behalf in terms of conditions
um and that is something we may be able
to resolve later on in the day okay well
you say me do giving the background so
would you like to get straight into that
so do you mind if I do you mind if I
interject a moment please if I um when
um when we we had a meeting yesterday
afternoon um myself the clients with Mr
par and Mr
and and uh we were trying to make
Headway on the conditions um there are
other discussions as well surrounding
the case uh my clients and I have had
the opportunity of looking again in in
some more detail at the proposed
conditions and we're prepared to
compromis to a greater degree than would
have been um clearer before because of
uh certain matters that were mentioned
in the meeting
yesterday um and I do think that it
would really benefit the committee if if
we had and I mentioned this this morning
to um uh to Mr par and also to uh Miss
Bo um I do think it will benefit uh to
have half an hour with the responsible
authorities uh to see if we can try and
reach agreement on those conditions it
might be that there isn't full agreement
but that we can certainly save time by
not having a debate about issues that
are capable of being resolved and I I do
think that would benefit the committee
in terms of how this
application
progresses uh the second part of that is
because I don't know what Mr Parry is
going to say in his opening submission I
I will at the moment and I hope this
doesn't prove to be necessary but I I
will at the moment have to reserve the
uh possibility that I may need to ask
for the case to be adjourned uh and I
raise that at this point only because I
don't know precisely what Mr par is
going to say but he he certainly has put
me on notice on the Wednesday morning
was it uh of a certain line of approach
which which is news to me will be news
to my clients and it's only right that I
raise that now but first and foremost is
really that request for half an hour to
try and see if we can reach agreement on
those
conditions think position of the
position of the uh responsible
authorities is the first question that
needs to be addressed is is whether or
not um that the license is capable of
continuing um and for reasons that I
will set out in my opening uh which I
offer to exchange with Mr cry some time
ago um we that is stage one if if
depending on your judgment and it's your
judgment it's not mine it's not Mr
Cryer's uh dependent on your judgment in
respect of that issue uh it would then
be the case as to whether conditions
become relevant or not uh and um it is
for that reason I would propose is to
open it so that we have put our case
clearly everybody knows what it is uh
and then we can we can make progress
from
there so if that is The Stance of Mr
parry and I feared it might be then I
would have to ask for the case to be
adjourned if you adopt that approach uh
for this
reason we received uh I'm talking about
we as in the company received an
application for a review of the premises
license for the to Victoria
Warehouse um which is supported by a
statement from uh mrw which uh include
which you have seen includes a lot of
historical
information and uh it also included a
set of
conditions uh we had a meeting with the
uh council with Mr lorth Mr Parry was
there for part of that meeting on the
19th of September and there was
discussion about those conditions and
there were one or two revisions made to
those conditions at that meeting
further Communications have taken place
and they have been directed solely uh
only and solely at the conditions and
what what the uh proposed conditions
that were put forward as part of the
review application were and uh certainly
in
Communications and there's been a number
of them we have put forward revised
revised version of those conditions some
of them were accepted some of them not
at no time up until
Wednesday morning of this week so
effectively two days ago has there been
any indication that this case would be
anything other than a discussion and a
review of those conditions the license
uh and I was not surprised at that
because there hasn't been any instant at
the premises that has led to this review
application it's not one of those you
know police Le uh reviews based on a
serious incident happening that there
been none so it's always been
a question of um the conditions and the
appropriate conditions and that's how
the discussions have progressed and so I
feel extremely uncomfortable being in
the position of a advising Premier uh
music venue operator in this country uh
being in a situation where they said Mr
cry if you feel that you can deal with
this uh review hearing based on it being
a a case about the conditions uh then go
ahead only to be in a situation where
effectively at the hearing to a certain
extent I'm put on notice to to the
extent that I was on Wednesday morning
that this is really a a question first
and foremost about whether the company
should be operating this
venue we're talking about a company here
that has 19 music venues across the
country they operate all those very
successfully you will probably be
familiar with the fact that we've just
undergone the company's just under gone
a review of the license at Brixton as a
result of a serious incidents and sad
fatalities that occurred in December
last year and we've come through that
process persuading the licensing
committee that it was uh the venue was
fit to reopen on the basis of a revised
set of conditions number of which we put
forward a number of which the local
Authority also put forward uh and in
that scenario uh then we are in a
situation where without any real pre
notice I'm going to have to report back
to the company and say well actually
this hearing that I've just had wasn't
just about conditions it was about
whether or not the uh company should
survive um uh this review process and on
that basis I then need to look at all
the
documentation together together with um
uh senior counil who will probably be
involved in the case um to review what
additional documentation should be
before this committee um because there's
a hell of a lot more that we can provide
to persuade this committee uh that it
should not be going down or not even be
considering going down the route of any
sanctions such as a revocation or a
suspension of the
license uh so I'm sorry I'm in that
position but um it's regrettable I was
hoping that this would be an application
my clients were hoping this would be an
application where we could try and reach
an accommodation on conditions which
have been put forward we've been
operating these premises since
2018 without any in incident of note
occurring the police have no objections
to this no other authority no residence
of objective we've agreed the noise
conditions and so I really did think
this was going to be a case about
conditions it obviously isn't and I
don't agree with an approach whereby we
have a preliminary test as to whether
this is a company that's St to operate
this venue and only then after you come
to a determination which isn't based
upon the consideration of the conditions
because that's brought to Mr par s Part
B approach to this uh I don't think that
that is an appropriate way for these
proceedings to be conducted and nor if
I'm perfectly Frank about it do I think
it's an appropriate way for the
responsible licensing Authority uh to be
presenting uh a company o o of my
client's repute uh which is a very
important company for the the operation
of the venue is very important to
traford uh to be putting us in a
position two days before a hearing
whereby it there's a suggestion that
this license is in Jeopardy so my
requests sir on that basis if this
approach is to be adopted uh would be to
us from the German I will move from that
request if we go back to the initial
position that I felt should be uh should
be adopted and that is that we have a
sensible further discussion with the uh
responsible licensing Authority uh on
the conditions and see if we can reach
agreement on those conditions that might
be a way of trying to move this
forward okay thank you I think Sher if
you may in order to hear to to to
evaluate that request for an adjournment
you really need to hear um what the
responsible authorities case is and I'm
quite happy to set out that history uh
and um address the points that Mr crier
has made um in order for you to be able
to you do that I've been I've been
advised by our legal officer to have a
five minute adjournment would would
would it be benefi in you doing that
doing that outlaying that now before we
have our adjournment so we at least
we've heard both sides of the argument
well I think it would enable you to go
out and make a decision as to um as to
whether or not there should be an
adjournment if I have done that and I've
addressed the points that Mr CER has
made um and
I do have I I know Mr cry doesn't want
me to set out the history but I I was
about to say I was I don't mind that as
long as it's not a full address on an
application for sanctions to be imposed
if Mr Parry is explaining why it is that
he now feels you know presume be in a
short shorten version of his opening
statement why he feels that the that the
adjournment request should be denied
then I will then respond to that sir but
uh I don't have an objection to theal
committee wants to know more about why
it is the local Authority responsible
licensing Authority want the case the
proceed right we we'll hear from Mr
parry and then we'll have a five minute
adour while we discuss the way forward
the starting point for a licensing
review is section 52 of the licensing
act 2003 it sets out that where a review
is to be determined as in this case the
authority must having regard to the
application and any relevant
representations take such of the steps
mentioned if any as it considers
appropriate for the promotion of the
licensing objectives the steps are to
modify the conditions of the license to
exclude a licensable activity from the
scope of the license to remove the
designated premises supervisor to
suspend the license for a period not
exceeding three months or to evoke the
license the hearing regulation sets out
that must be considered uh at a public
hearing and it follows from that that
once the process has been started the
decision-making process is handed over
to you and doesn't remain in the hands
of the offices um their opportunity is
if they consider it appropriate to uh
remove uh a a ground of objection or in
this case
application and the guidance makes it
clear that you are supposed to um in so
far as possible seek to establish the
cause or causes of the concerns that the
representations identify the remedial
action that should generally be directed
at those causes and should be no more
than appropriate and proportionate to
address the causes of concern that uh
instigated uh the
review uh and I'm also uh minded to uh
refer to some other case law which is
the case of uh
uh Regina V nightsbridge Crown Court X
party International sporting club London
limited um that it is right that
licensing justices or the Crown Court on
appeal should have regard the fact that
it is in the public interest that the
sanction of cancellation of a license
should not be devalued it is obvious
that the possibility the loss of the
license must be a powerful incentive in
this case to conso operators to observe
the gaming laws and run their premises
properly a licensing Authority is fully
entitled to use sanction of cancellation
in the public interest to encourage
other operators or would be operators of
gaming establishments to observe the law
in the area of their jurisdiction so
what is the background to this case well
it goes back to
2019 um and on that occasion uh there
was uh an enforcement
visit um sorry on the 9th of
by Miss Duckworth when as she sets out
in her statement she witnessed a lack of
control over people queing for the event
uh and when being dispersed thereafter
they were queuing on Trafford walk road
where they were at risk of being struck
by vehicles and of course we know that
in the current environment particularly
given current news the possibility of
somebody being deliberately run over as
occurred on Westminster Bridge canot be
ruled out on examination there was no
provision written or otherwise that was
capable of protecting the public who
were queuing on the 9th of June also on
that occasion uh Miss Duckworth
inspected medical facilities they lacked
hot water the premises Li told told them
that the problems were were told what
needed to be done to sort that those
matters out by a letter on the 18th of
July 2019 you that in your bundle as nd1
in appendix 2 and whilst it might have
been expected from what we are told the
premier music venue to put those things
right uh it wasn't put right because on
the 5th of um February
2020 there was a fur there were further
problems with crowd management during
admission and exit from the premises the
risk assessments that were available
failed to demonstrate any appreciation
of the difficulties that arose when
events Victoria Warehouse clashed with
those being held at Manchester United
Trafford ground uh which is adjacent
very nearly to the premises and a
further warning was letter was sent out
on the 20th of February
2020 there was no response to that
letter sir Chaser was sent out on the
12th of March
2020 on the 16th of March 2020 the first
coid lockdown began and for no fault of
anybody's the premises had to
close on the 12th of May 2021 Kieran
hinchliff the then Senior licensing
obvious with the council sent an email
to Lee Atkinson at the O2 Warehouse
inquiring about their plans for
reopening and in particular seeking the
license holders plans to safely manage
the egress Ingress of members of the
public to The Venue there was at that
time uncertainty again not the fault of
the license holder or anybody else's of
what events would be able to be run
however the necessary plans about safely
managing the crowns have not been
received uh by the 9th of July 2021
causing Mr hinch to write to the venue
again the coid restrictions were
eventually lifted and that allowed the
venue to reopen on the 6th of September
2021 the event that took place that
night was observed by Suzanne wha and
Nicha duas when it was apparent that
very little had changed in relation to
the management of queuing event
Arrangements at the venue as Miss
Whitaker observed in her email exhibit
10 D6 in your bundle uh to The Venue on
the 7th of September she said it's vital
you stop cues forming along the pavement
Miss Whitaker proposed license holder
arranged queuing in an adjacent car park
and warned that if we find that this
system is not being used on future
visits a health and safety prohibition
notice will be served there was another
event scheduled for the 21st of
September
2021 which coincided with a football
match that was to be played uh at the
Manchester United ground that meant the
adjac b car park which the license
holder had permission to use for queing
uh was not available in cons in
consequence M Duckworth made an inquiry
of the venue to establish how the venue
proposed to manage queing and was told
that it was intended to queue patrons
along the traford walk road something
the previous premises license holder
been something premises license holder
been told previously was unaccept
acceptable and where prohibition would
repetition would lead to the service
prohibition notice there repetition and
an enforcement notice was served that's
at ND
08 there is a right of appeal against
enforcement notices issued under the
health and safety legislation it's a
right anybody can take up and that is
conceded and that was taken up on this
case so we are told um but the usual
process whereby the employment tribunal
to whom such uh appeals will be made
notify the respondent the Council of in
this case of the appeal uh we've never
had that
notification and when challenged by the
validity of the the appeal we were shown
a letter saying suggesting theal have
been sent to the London and Southeast
employment trium which surprises us
because the Hearing Centers for the
employment tribunal here are in
Manchester and in Liverpool and we've
had nothing that suggests that that is
ongoing save an insurance from Mr cry
that it is uh but the very best that can
be said about that has been that nothing
has been done to further it and that is
relevant we say because it the effect of
such a notice is to suspend certain
enforcement actions that could be taken
about the prohibition of such
conditions Mr Duckworth however
continued to work with the premises
license holder uh as the queing uh
queuing additions were not being
adequately adjust especially on Match
Days by December
2021 her her powers were
were were severely limited but it is
worth looking at the grounds of appeal
the grounds of appeal ground seven the
measures specified in the schedule form
part of the Improvement exceeds the duty
under sections two and section three of
the health and safety at work act 1974
namely to ensure the safe Ingress and
egress for all people attending at the
event well we would say it would be
obvious that queuing people down that
busy road is not ensuring their
safety on the 15th of September
2022 uh at Brixton Academy the incident
Mr crier alluded to a little earlier
took place that was an incident where um
the crowds managed to gain entrance to
uh the premises in the ensuing melee and
Crush uh two people uh died and several
others were
injured it's against that history and
all of those all of the officers here
would be inclined to send their
condolences to the family of those
people but there is also a determination
and we said there should be
determination by everybody to sure that
nothing like that occurs in Trafford um
because that is the function of the
public safety uh criteria of of the
licensing
regime so it's appropriate to look to
what has happened later
on in May
2022 um the general manager overseeing
the O O2 Victoria Warehouse was changed
Lee Atkinson left and he was replaced by
Mr Russell Taylor toll who is new
designated premises
supervisor on the 6th of February 2023
the premises were visited once more
there were causes of concern there was
an absence of hot water in the premises
bars for the purposes of cleaning and
handwashing which amounted to a breach
of the food safety and hygiene
regulations
2013 and the health and safety at
workout 1972 Section 3 there was no hot
water in the lady's toilets and some
thingss uh there was no hot water within
the medical facility in circumstances
when this had gone unnoticed because the
inspection was done three hours into the
event the floor in the medical room was
dirty and required either deep cleaning
or replacement there were inadequate
infection controls and South was seen
sitting on their on the beds in there uh
with their feet up leaving Footprints
there was inad qu evidence as to how the
premises holder had calculated the
maximum capacity of each individual area
within the premises and was ensuring
that maximum capacity was not exceeded
the designated premises supervisor Mr
Taylor tol's response to an email
pointing out those defects can be seen
in the bundle at exhibit nd12 and was
sent on the 7th of February
2023 that response sets out that
portable water heaters been ordered for
the temporary bars but they were due to
be delivered on the 10th of February 4
days after the event which had been held
events had been made since the visit to
order and construct temporary washing
stations um similarly as a result of the
visit the premisis license holder had
found that the hot water system in the
venue had had a fault that prevented it
from producing six sufficient hot water
at peak times in so far as the lady's
toilets were concerned Mr Taylor toll
explained that some Taps have been
damaged during recent shows and apped
that there were some adequate watering
facilities save that washrooms were
served by the same inadequate hot water
system there were assurance that
additional concerns about the safety of
food preparation orders uh had been
remedied and that the floor in the
medical room had been deep cleaned and
replaced in so far of crowd management
of an area known as chai and the
mezzanine was concerned Mr duas was told
on the date of the visit that the
company was currently on working on
putting a plan together a remark that we
say carries the inference that although
those areas were being used there was no
plan for managing them at all the
concern of the responsible authorities
is that all these defects and the
absence of plans would have been obvious
to a reasonable competent premises
manager they should have prompted
remedial action before the absence of
plans and defects came to the attention
of enforcement actions particularly
given the previous um enforcement
history
Mr Taylor told was some circumstance
circumspect as to when for example Taps
have been damaged during earlier shows
and that begs the question as to how
long the venue was allowed offense to
proceed in the knowledge that those
defects existed and why he had not
caused them to be put right the same
considerations go to all the other
defects on the 20th of February 2023 in
response to an email sent to M Taylor
told chasing a response the defects
highlighted on the 6th of February 2 and
23 Miss Duckworth received a generic
stewarding plan that was not considered
to be
adequate on the 7th of SE February
2023 Mr Taylor toll stated that uh that
he would Supply structural calculations
to demonstrate that the mezanine was C
capable of bearing the weight of those
using it within 14 days those
calculations were not received within
that time frame although the figures
suggesting that the maximum capacity of
each area supplied they didn't establish
the basis of them on the 21st of April
2023 this is exhibit nd4 Mr Taylor toll
sought to up to dat M Miss Duckworth as
to works that have been carried out in
relation to the hot water and hygiene uh
issues and requested a review of The
onear Food hygiene rating that had been
awarded to the V on the 6th of February
2023 a one-star food rating means that
major Improvement is necessary on the
21st of April um it also it also
included weightbearing evidence and that
was submitted to Amy who advise the
Council on such matters a structural
engineer said that they were inadequate
and sought further information as to the
basis upon which those had been done
Chaser emails to secure that had to be
sent on the 17th of May the 19th June
and the 10th of August
2023 the concerns of the responsible
authorities were that the premises
managers should have been certain that
the premises was safe and fit for
purpose before staging any events and
that was not being done and the fact
that these were real and legitimate were
underlined in a p reports provided to
Allison Acton nd7 on behalf of the
premises license holder which
recommended reducing the capacity of the
mezzanine area from 660 people to 25
until adequate checks had been
undertaken on the 23rd of August
2023 a further enforcement uh visit took
place before uh a TV girl uh event took
place on that occasion there was no
football taking place and queing was
taking place in the adjacent car park
the attending officers requested
specific health and safety risk
assessments they were not produced the
officers were told that the risk
assessments were being reviewed by Live
Nation a separate company from premises
license holder AMG the two being closely
linked it's essential we say that in
order to be effective risk assessments
need to be prepared and put into
practice before the event takes place
not afterwards a generate some documents
were provided but they were inadequate a
gener generic assessment dealing with
medical provision was provided but only
considered risk in so far as the
provided staff were concerned and not
the risk of uh to venue staff or persons
attending the event the medical team on
the site expressed the view to
enforcement officers that they've been
moved from their usual provision to a
new location which was difficult to
reach a casualty should an incident
occur the other documents that have been
provided completed by an external
security company were not event specific
and did not address crowd control during
that visit Mr Taylor told the DPS told
the officers that a building control
certificate for change in use had been
found
further in requiring reveal that works
that have been undertaken were not the
subject of the completion certificate
and had not been signed off structural
calculations that went to the use of the
first fall building were passed over and
were considered by the council's
structural engineers were found to be
inadequate in consequence Alison Acton
one of the council's health and safety
officers issued a Prohibition order
exhibit nd1 18 against supremacist
license holder which prohibited the use
of the first floor until such time as
the appropriate structural assessments
have been carried out and in an Evidence
of those assessments have been passed to
council the results of that were not for
um those calculations to be passed over
but for an appeal you can find it at an
nd20 to be uh lodged uh in which um they
um they sought the suspension of uh the
notice and the first ground of that was
that Allison Acton was wrong to form the
opinion she did that of course we say
sits very uneasily with amg's report
that in far so far as the mezzanine deck
was concerned the capacity should be
reduced from 660 to 25 people until
adequate safeguards have been put in
place the second ground again we say
inconsistent with uh amg's own reports
is that the the appellant that the
inspector failed to specify the basis
upon which Miss Acton formed the view
that there was a risk of overloading um
well it's fairly obvious that that was
because of what she was told and the
third ground was that the flaw was sound
but that of course was something that at
the time no one was willing to
demonstrate in fact they were able to
demonstrate that and they did so on the
5th of October
2023 when sufficient calculations were
passed over caused ing causing the um
notice to be no longer of effect that we
say is the date upon which the Lo
the um premises license holder could
have been or the date he received that
report could have been the date that
they were satisfied that it was safe but
no
earlier we accept of course that there
is a right of appeal but what we say is
that the fact that that was done rather
than producing the document ation is
consistent with um a review that it's
it's going to be all right on the night
and that is something that we say is a
matter of
concern additionally having reviewed the
documentation that was provided Allison
act and provided identified further
breaches of sections two and three of
the health and safety at work act I
should explain those are the two
sections that require you to protect
your employees and those visiting your
premises uh in terms of health and
safety
legislation um she served an improvement
notice on the premises license holder
requiring them to produce site specific
and event specific documents identifying
the specific risks and control measures
that will be put in place that notice
has not been appealed and about 5:00 on
the 5th of October Mr Cryer produced
various documents uh in purported
compliance with the right notice they
have been looked at and reviewed and
they are not considered to be adequate
by the um the the council's offices and
indeed as late as yesterday uh at a
meeting Mr CER has alluded to we set out
um why it is that they are not
considered uh necessary so in relation
to Mr cry saying he is surprised about
the councils or the responsible
authorities take on this matter it has
always been the case that once a review
has been launched all options are are
open it is the case that we know from
figures that AMG have produced and you
can see it the up page 70 of your bundle
but since
593 385 people have attended events at
the Victoria Warehouse it is predicted
that by the end of this year in the same
fig
73,500 more people will enter that
building and
229,000 people are due to attend next
year at the moment on the basis of the
information that the responsible
authorities have have seen they cannot
be
satisfied that there are adequate risk
Assessments in place to protect those
people and under those circumstances and
given and I take on board what uh Mr
crier says about AMG it is a prominent
company uh it has a turnover according
to its last reported accounts in
company's House of 75 million pounds
very nearly and an operating profit of
just over4 million pounds and we take
all that on board but it is the view of
the responsible authorities that in this
case a venue of that type should be
leading the way should be carrying the
torch and should be operating their
premises safely and the responsible
authorities are not satisfied and it is
for that reason one we oppose an
adjournment because of the delay that
that would cause and secondly it is a
matter of disappointment that here we
are on the 20th of October and we still
do not have adequate risk assessments
and we cannot say to you yes we are
content with what we have been provided
with so that is the council's position
and that is why we oppose this
application for anern thank you Mr Parry
so clearly you've identify a lot of
serious issues which has triggered this
review just just on
the um the prohibition order um that's
been as you say it's been appealed and I
believe there's a there's a a
hearing we um we told that there's been
a hearing I haven't seen documentation
from the employment tribunal yet I
understand it's on its way and there is
to be a hearing in November but that is
redundant because the notice has ceased
to be of any effect because of course uh
AMG has now provided the structural
calculations upon which they rely and it
is their risk to say that that floor is
safe so that notice is of no that notice
is of no effect anymore and there is no
point in using valuable Court time or
employment tribunal time progressing an
appeal and I believe that that is um
it's not Mr CER that has conducted that
matter it's another firm that solicitors
for AMG but I believe that that point is
conceded by them but there is some
ongoing negotiations about that so we
still need to consider it it is it is
they have they have complied with the
prohibition notice they have not
complied with the Improvement notices um
it is relevant that the prohibition
notice had to be issued and that is why
we put it before
you okay so just to be clear I know um
that there's been a lot of
Correspondence to do with the
conditions and meetings to try and get
agreement are are you clearly saying
that you you want to go for a revocation
or that we say has to be the starting
point because unless we can be satisfied
not US unless you can be satisfied that
the um premises license holder has the
ability the intent and the capacity to
op at the premises safety uh the
difficulty that we have is how can
anybody be satisfied that there is an
intention to uphold Public Safety parts
of the licensing objectives and and and
we say that looking looking back over
the the uh enfor um enforcement history
there has to be great doubts about
that it is right that we should lay them
before
you okay I'm going to ask for brief
adjourn is there anything you'd like to
say before we actually do that yes I do
need to respond to this I'm sorry it's
um a very reversible situation this
because um I I do reinforce the point
that I I strongly believe I've been
hijacked um in this respect um up until
two days ago there was never any
suggestion uh that this case would be
anything other than about uh a review of
the conditions on the license
and it's unsatisfactory for the company
to be in a position where the licensing
Advocate is reporting back to say well I
I hadn't uh uh prepared fully for all
the documentation considerable
additional documentation that this
committee must see in response to the
allegations and the suggestions that
have been said made by Mr Parry uh much
of which we uh would have to disagree
with uh much of which we would have to
challenge much of which we would have to
explain and I'm simply not in that
position to do so today and I hope my
clients have uh my support with with
that uh the simple position is of course
I do know uh a considerable amount of
background but what what Mr Parry has
failed to explain is that there is a
difference here between the licensing
regime and what is required in the
licensing regime and what is happening
with in relation to the prohibition an
improvement notice action which I not
instructed on I do have some of the
background knowledge of it but I'm not
instructed on it and there is a
conflation of the two here by suggesting
that the appropriate documentation is
not before the council but before the
responsible licensing authority to
enable them to say to you that they're
satisfied with that
documentation and here is the problem
that we provided to the responsible
licensing Authority Mr Parry asked for
all Communications to be directed
through him uh we provided considerable
event management plan documentation on
the 5th of October a considerable amount
of documentation in fact it's shown in
the uh EMP the event management plan
that that you were provided with this
additional documentation I submitted
later and you'll see that there's an
appendix there which lists all the
various documents that were provided as
part of that process that was all
provided on the fifth of October as part
of the licensing review application it
wasn't specifically relevant to although
there was some crossover wasn't
specifically relevant to the
documentation for the um for the
Improvement notice uh action that's been
requested the Improvement notice um
required the documentation to be
provided by the 20th of October and that
additional documentation not provided by
me but by my clients and those
instructing in fact by the health and
safety consultant uh for the uh company
that was provided in accordance with
that direction on the 19th of October so
basically yesterday I think
I'm
today so they have complied with the
Improvement notice requirement and what
Mr Parry is now saying is Well we don't
that documentation to be adequate what
it actually means is that they've not
reviewed it yet um because that was told
to me yesterday in the meeting in the
afternoon it hadn't been fully reviewed
but they have reviewed the documentation
that was provided in respect of the
licensing application the documentation
provided on the 5th of October there was
a request for additional information in
relation to crowd management issues and
the balcony um assessment capacity
assessment so an updated version was
provided on the 16th of October um so
three days four days ago and indeed that
was also provided to the licensing
Authority at the same time
so understand that at this point
including 16th of October right through
until Wednesday this week I considered
that that documentation that was
provided on the 5th of October with the
update uh following a request for
additional information provided um on
the 16th of October was really what had
been asked for what in fact we said we
would provide at the meeting that was
held on the 19th of September and that
was all relevant to this discussion
about moving forward with discussions we
even started a discussion on the on the
sorry on the conditions we even started
a discussion on the conditions on the
19th of September it's never been
anything other than the discussion about
conditions up until uh the are should I
say bomb of an email um that's implied
that there might be another
consideration and that is the one that
Mr Parry is now outlining to you uh
basically no we should be looking at
whether or not the committee feel that
the license should be uh revoked well
that is extremely unfair because the
basing part of that decision on comments
that they say documentation is
inadequate when it's not being fully
reviewed and so it reinforces uh the
point that I've made that if this is a
hearing that's not just about a review
of the conditions basically any review
should be looking forward you know what
are we going to do to address issues of
concern if it isn't about the conditions
um then I've been left left in the
position of saying well you know why is
it that the committee have being asked
to revoke a license they've been asked
to revoke a license because the the
responsible licensing Authority is
saying they're not satisfied on
documentation that's been provided to
them um two weeks ago
and we've only had one comment there was
an email as well which we explain uh
some some of the uh queries that came
through I think yesterday as
well so this is a very unsatisfactory
decision it actually reinforces the
point that I made before that clearly
what needs to be done here is for the
responsible licensing authority to
review the comprehensive documentation
that has been sent this is in two parts
first of all the 5th of October
documentation the event management plan
all the appendices relevant to the
license that was which we said we will
provide to review all that to come back
to see whether there's any particular uh
further comments that they have in
relation to that because it's
unsatisfactory to say to AE or not we
don't consider it to be adequate but not
yet identify what it is they do consider
to be inadequate and so the committee is
left in a position today of thinking
that it's inadequate when we believe
it's not secondly the adjournment would
allow a proper consideration of the
conditions that um uh that I said that I
think we can get very close with if not
in fact get those agreed obviously
subject to the committee feeling that
conditions are
appropriate thirdly it would enable me
to report back to my clients uh for them
to consider the position in relation to
what additional documentation and there
will be additional documentation we can
provide to satisfy this committee that
the many of the matters that have been
put forward here
today in a format that suggests there
truth behind them that there is another
side to that story I haven't prepared
documentation of that nature because I
didn't think that was a case this was a
case where that was being considered to
be relevant as I said before this has
always been a discussion about
conditions and then the fourth point to
support the uh request from the gourment
is that Mr par is saying well we don't
consider documentation in relation to
the Improvement notice to be adequate
and the reason he saying that is because
it's not yet been reviewed fully the
person who will be reviewing it um um
sorry
for Alis Alis Aton is back off leave
next week and we built that into the
compliance timetable uh for her to be
able to review that properly next week
so it's not fair
it's unreasonable for a committee to be
told well this is um inadequate
documentation and it's relevant to the
health and safety procedings not the
licensing proceedings but it hasn't yet
been fully reviewed so the adjournment
the fourth point of requ will be to
allow that um uh time to to elapse a
proper considered time and to take some
of the heat out of this quite frankly
because I I do find this this approach
rather astonishing from the uh from the
responsible licensing authorities
representative I must say there is
another Factor
here you know one of the reasons for
opposing the jum is well you know that's
time that would pass
whereby um you know the premises would
continue to operate suggesting that it
would be in that it would be operating
inadequately that's simply not the case
in every single instance uh going back
to um the discussions about the traffic
management plan um in 2021 2022 that
been a series of meetings and I even
provided to uh the licensing Authority
and I put the uh Mr K on notice of this
a minute of a meeting that took place on
the 1st of February
2022 uh which discussed about the
traffic management plan approach and a
document followed on from that and then
there was nothing the my clients didn't
hear hear anything further about that
this is another matter that really needs
to get into the detail of what this
committee would need to see um in full
proper documented format so again it's
very unfair there more recent
Communications my clients have been
addressing each one we provided the
documentation to satisfy the prohibition
notice we provided documentation which
we believe satisfies the Improvement
notice but that was only provided uh the
the other day which is perfectly in
accordance with the ch
we do need that time to be able to
prepare this uh fully if this is a case
where the committee is being asked to
consider first and foremost whether or
not the license should be uh should
should be revoked or or suspended that
that is simply not fair the the other
point being of course that um this is a
an application for review of a license
it seems to be complated with health and
safety enforcement um matters that are
still ongoing prohibition notti is dealt
with but the other matters are still
ongoing the 2021 Improvement notice
appeal yes it seems to have been lost in
the system frankly but I know that Mr
Parry chased the employment tribunal
about that in 2022 he copied me in and
so I was expecting the employment
tribunal to respond to that they never
did but it became irrelevant because the
matters that gave rise to that
Improvement notice were addressed by my
clients anyway so they've actually dealt
with that issue as they have tried to
deal with each and every other issue and
finally there is no Prejudice to an
adjournment because the premises would
operate um continue to operate even if
the committee came to a decision today
to revoke the license or suspend the
license because it doesn't take any
effect until an appeal is determined and
quite
frankly I don't like using this phrase
because it seems like uh you know
lawyers use of language inappropriately
but quite honestly
the the company would not feel that they
would have had a fair hearing today if
it results in uh a revocation or a
suspension of the license which would
not take effect until an appeal is
determined and the company would appeal
of course because then at least it would
have the opportunity of presenting all
the full documentation before the appeal
court the magistrates Court which would
be months in in in months time many
months time but you know we still
continue we've always said we will
continue to work with the council we're
continuing to work with the council now
we've provided the documentation we want
if they're not happy about something let
them tell us and we will look at it and
address it and I know Mr hland over many
years that has always been his approach
we have a very good record across all
the authorities we know that there was a
very unfortunate uh incident the very
sad incident in December 2022 uh and the
company as you would expect has leared
some lessons from that in its process of
persuading and um and the licensing
Authority being satisfied that the
premises will be able to reopen uh we
don't want another situation where we
have to go through all that we believe
we can uh meet the tests but we need the
time uh to first of all provide allow
the authority to consider the
documentation that's been provided if
there's anything else that they think is
necessary um then we will do so what is
not fair is to person be hijacked in
this situation as I've mentioned
before okay thank you so I mean we have
to have an adjournment to see which way
where we're going to go with this
whether we go down the replication or
the conditions
rout Mr Parry would you be in a position
to present a case if we went down
conditions with or you clearly saying
that it's revocation or nothing we have
we have provided what we say are
necessary conditions to Mr crier he says
that some of them are not acceptable to
his clients um we we we we we put the
matter before you on the basis that we
can't F your hands as to which way you
go uh we don't SE to do so we simply say
that kicking the can down the road
doesn't saf guard those who are going to
attend the meetings but yes if you are
ready to proceed um we are ready to
proceed just on that as I said we have
been able to review those conditions uh
I think quite a number can be accepted
there will be some debate it might be
better taking that outside the Committee
hearing so we can try and get agreement
if the committee feels that that's the
right way forward today um but if it is
on the first approach then i' strongly
and must reinforce the fact that we
would ask for it to be a j feel person
just ask our Le thank you yes if I could
just come in I'm just concerned that
obviously the licensing committee here
it's it's important to set out what the
remit is of the committee and it is as
as Mr Perry's mentioned earli on I just
want to reemphasize it it it section 52
of the legislation does give the
licensing subcommittee a wide remit of
what it's actually considering today so
I think it would be wrong to get caught
in a um an ARB approach where it's
either we're either looking at
conditions or revocation because that
implies there some fettering going on of
the licensing subcomm
this is a qu Quai judicial committee
where there are a whole range of web of
different outcomes that the licensing
that committee can consider it's
certainly not looking at just conditions
or
revocation um there's a whole range of
things under the legislation that um
it's right that the subcomittee consider
depending on the representations that
put forward so I think that's really
important just to come back to basics on
that we're not considering one or the
other um so I think to clarify at the
moment what we're considering is do we
have an adjournment or not are we having
an adjournment or not but can I just go
back a step Mr cry before we got onto
the adjournment argument you did um
request um another meeting for half an
hour to look at the conditions is that
something you still wish to have or you
now just ask if we're aour and I think
we a situation so it's a very difficult
one this never had this in my career
spends over 35 years now in licensing um
we're in a a situation where I'm very
uncomfortable about this case proceeding
uh for various reason I do accept that
you know of course the committee has
full Powers but you know you present a
case on the basis of the evidence that's
been provided but also on the
discussions this was not an application
that said the review application did not
say we are seeking a a replication of
license suspension of the license it
came attached with a lot of conditions
and the discussion was about those
conditions so I as it said before I do
feel that unless this is a a situation
where the committee feel okay let's move
forward to some discussion about
conditions it might be appropriate then
to uh have 30 minutes with the
responsible licensing authority to um to
look at those um and in fact you know
really if you put this in Reverse how
can the committee determine the
situation that no we should be looking
at revocation when you haven't even
considered the alternative of what the
conditions are that are being put
forward to address them so so I am left
really I'm afraid with saying that I I
am very uncomfortable about this my
clients will be and I would have to ask
for an adjournment for the various
reasons I'm not going to repeat them
thank
you okay thank you for that so we we'll
we'll have a a short adjournment to see
which way we're going to go I've been
pointed out until we finish the
discussion still clearly lots of options
are open to us to V or to amend the
conditions or to exclude parts of the
licensing part of the scope of the
license so if I anybody's got anything
to say at this stage I'm going to ask
forour for a few minutes you leave yes
please thank
you